танець важливі для вас комора постановкою його
репетирує особливо бік лінії 16 го
на вигляд побачи а за хореографію у na'vi
постановки the true переселенця
дітей-солдат і режисер gyorgy народного
займати чини
in ж багата уроки проти і в Україні
говорити я
кожен учень і слух це 1 1 слухайте
один одного ми перебуваємо а у потрапити не і
на великому містечку на донбасі us he
будинку на премію всього вийти за бла кого
не
он і видути до зони бойових дій
ночі вул і ночуючи стріляний ну а ви
сьогодні його нас із реджина на прем'єрі
піски
ну думаю історії раз побачити і 2 100
хто вершить не навершення самої історії
спить там наш хлопчик про свого молодшого
брата до матвій елліна розкажи сьогодні
каліцтво rise сцени хештег тариф з
контрольно-пропускного пункту на всюди
містечку
солдат і завив і гуска якова назвала
навали обраного президента США
трампа що-небудь трамп вороги україни по
містам і його зима
лейтенант пастушок показуючи нам свою
допомога коня підземний бункер за його
слова малюки за дикою театральною
проекту
йому вдалося налагодити контакт із місцели
молоддю
мого сну вам припинялася а і старшим
поколінням старшим поколінням я за 3
роки ми будь розлютився пак і я не хочу
життя ми говорити та авто ми всі їм
поперековому і не американії
що у нас соціальний американський
автомат буду на культурі місця тато сну
у вечорі перед початком вистави у
сестри лівани місцями петлі такі
солдати спина працювала нації
документальну постановку
що але куди ти будеш пахан вас вміє
ці протікати йому тут їжа вина і у нас
акторські групі та люди doom клейких не
збігаються
сам цьому його жив його щоб у театрі
була чоловік вивести вислав цією своєю
богині у нас вона слухала вистав
починається деки для дачі прийшли сюди і
просто з фронту тут брови в руках
[музика]
своїх історіях солдати вкотре повідають про
фронтовику дні для розлучення середніми
і кухонними лейтенант пастушок по
головному зеку вгору руках вони я про тубу
і про холодну ніч бункері
на жаль раніше холодна їх начинкою
я тут ціни місяць youth та
inci історії в проживши і провини брата колін
і матерів теж у залі та слуху та києва
сестра руставі та я про страх перед
смертю та до Івановича лоза свого
маленького брата в один момент коли
снаряд з правдою вам настільки близько я
дивлюся на нього авен клуб із замов shop
мовчати я не знаю знижки windows може
10 20 секунд мовчки
севр їжте вирішить добрий закінчилася а її
молодший брат
знову змов проза померлих і
поранених ти ж говорила на приклад про
дядька eg і загну вигляд ви баху гранати
плакати не стыдно цінне означає з
лапкою це означає щити живі
рощин цієї покаже out on se згадкою
полешок та душевну травму
ми that you god eater ального проекту
більше ніш просто виставок
green повинен допомогти людям великого
тирана вид провини
[музика]
з вами я спаровуються і проект
терапія до чого у нас у цій ніс проти
шкірки щоб поліпшити в нього знаєш вин
на сам від неї у своїй біді та в радості
тут погляду пекельний залі пляшку культури
містечко тато сну на сході України
політика йшла на інший план